OK hello everyone good morning good afternoon and good evening wherever you
are thank you so much for joining us today in this session
on introduction to mantra autopilot now we do
have an interesting session lined up for today but before we go ahead and start
there are a few housekeeping roles that I would want to share with you
this session is being recorded and during the session
you are more than welcome to post your questions in the Q&A tab they will
be taken up either during or towards the end of the session depending on the time
on the time.
And any unanswered questions will be answered offline and made available on
the SharePoint.
It was the end of the session of course I will share the thread link in the
Q&A window so please do not forget to claim your credits
for this session the link will be in the feature tab of your Q and
A panels.
And that's all from my end so with that I
would like to hand over the session to our presenters
for today vikas pratap Singh so vikas over to you now
Thank you, Sakshi and yeah.
Hello, ladies and gentlemen. Welcome to the session.
Of Nokia mentoray autopilot my name is
vikas I'm the product manager who is current
currently working in the manta
Fine product that is meant that a autopilot.
During this the course of this presentation uh what
we will do is we will look into the uh the
details of uh what autopilot is first
first, we'll look into the background. What?
What were the reasons behind which drove
the creation of this product autopilot will then
look into how it works what value it brings
brings, and so on.
Then we'll look at some customer use cases.
Umm the results that we have achieved uh from our differe
different customers uh we'll then move on to a bit of umm
umm the the vision that we
have for autopilot and where we want to head
So this will be the agenda of this discussion.
On the panel I have Mohan with me you know
Mohan is one of the senior architects and ment
mentor is on team he
is one of the key brains behind autopilot
as a product so yeah
Mohan will be helping
me answer a lot of difficult questions that
may be coming from you and because they are difficult they go to Mohan
Umm along with Mohan I have raya and Priya also
in this call with me from the product portfolio management
team umm I'm sure they don't need any
interaction umm they will help us out
Any brand related questions or anything like that?
OK so before I get into the discussion probably I'll
switch off the video just to make sure that the
bandwidth is not hogged by my face
and we focus mostly on the discussion
itself on the material that is being shared so
So that we start that.
OK so.
What is autopilot autop
autopilot is a cloud native AI driven network
optimization solution as you know network opt
optimization is one of the.
Most challenging aspects that our customers face
and doing it manually is is is
a daunting task it's not something that is really
advisable to do so that
that is where the mentary autopilot comes into picture.
As he said it's a cloud native AI driven network optimization
solution it leverages both on
supervised and unsupervised learning to to
contextualise the whole network and provide very
very precise optimization.
What it does is it proactively analyses the network
performance it generates data driven
recommendations with fine tuned parameters which is very which are
are very precise in nature.
Uh it assesses the network objectives and then presents
those insights in a very user friendly uh
interface and that is what our autopilot
as a product is in just will
of course be getting into the details of this product in the
Now before we go into the details of the
autopilot let's first understand the background that
or the underlying reasons which led to this decision
of creating autopilot as an
as an individual independent product.
Those who have been working with manta
rayson would already know that this
offering was called Cognitive Son earlier.
And there was a conscious decision taken that
autopilot should be an independent
product and not just a value pack within
the.
What were the reasons that drove us to this discussion
Well.
The first reason is that we wanted to have independent
contract negotiations uh which are free from any
baggage of the existing zone contracts that we have had
and and the nature those contracts have been
been built upon.
The next very important aspect was
in general the product revi vital
vitalization now here is a product and which
is plantaray autopilot which truly reflect
reflects our commitment towards bringing a solution
Into the AI for ran portfolio right
we want to address that Dom
domain that is where autopilot comes into picture
picture.
It brings in a level 4 autonomous
operations uh into the fold uh which
we wanted to have demarcated vis
visibility from the Level 3
automation that comes from the mantra song that
is the reason we wanted autopilot to have its own identity
which clearly defines that OK this is a AI
is a AI driven product.
Which brings in.
Another level of automation on top of the
existing mentary saw.
Also umm as of today
umm what autopilot is doing is it's
orchestrating this on modules of course but we
do not want that to be restrict
restricted only to this much scope we
want that scope to enhance we don't want
that scope to increase and eventually we want autopilot
to evolve into orchestrating even custom
objectives and custom modules and custom objectives are customers
Example have uh hundreds of uh
adapted modules of their own we want autopilot to be
able to orchestrate those modules as well not
just the standard song modules and
in future when we get into the smo business
we want this autopilot
to be able to orchestrate our apps custom our apps and 3rd
and 3rd party our apps as well.
So these were the reasons.
Behind.
The decision of announcing autopilot as an individ
individual independent product.
During this course of presentation we'll talk about level
4 automation quite often so here I just want to
explain what are different levels what
is this level 4 so we have this forum
called Tele management forum as you would already know which defines various
various levels of autonomous operations.
Now to be at level 4.
The solution or the the product needs to be able to
make intent based.
Decisions autonomously Nokia
already has that offering which is autopilot
and it caters to uh umm various
used cases key used cases uh
with level 4 autonomous operation right and
right? And that is why.
It's important that we segregate it from the typical
automated solution that we have had so far.
So let's look at the evolution journey of autopilot
And it starts with the need to autom
automate the whole network optimization itself if
we we do not have any kind of automation and the operator
operator has to handle it manually.
It's a daunting task you have to manually monitor the
KPIs you have to do analysis identify where
the network performance degradations are happening then
you have to manually map the solutions using some scripts or
you have to create the correction forms manual plans
manually to fix the problem and once those solutions
solutions are applied.
Then verify the results manually and if the need be rolled it back
and this may take weeks, maybe months.
Then came uh our classic song
the Mandarin song which provides a human
human led automated solution.
It comes with automated report generation for any
kind of problem analysis.
Umm the solution mapping uh it comes in the
form of various on used cases on modules uh but
then which some module has to be applied where that is
that is decided by the operator manually
basically it's a experience based Sol
And once the solution has been deployed we talk about that that that
is when the verification the rollback part comes into picture where
manually one has to verify the outcome and
if there is a need trigger the
automated rollback but at least trigger it initiate it
Manually after the analysis of.
The results of our solution orchestration.
Autopilot brings in the next level of automation
The entire analysis of the network.
The the objectives of the network and the
thresholds the performance KPIs everything is auton
autonomously analysed by the autopilot without
without any manual intervention.
The solutions are pre mapped as of now so you have
these on modules which are mapped
to the objectives that we have and what those objectives
objectives are. We'll look into them in the coming slides.
They are already mapped and they are deployed only on the
problematic cells not in the entire network only on the
problematic sense with precise
precise calibration.
Even the verification of the result
is autonomous where it can be auto verified and
and needed adjustments can be done automatically.
So this is the evolution journey of autopilot.
And with that you see the human intervention has reduced now
how exactly it works uh we will look into this
and this particular slide now if
you look at any network optim
optimization operation, these are various phases.
First one is you have
to identify what is the object objective towards which we are
running any network optimization operation or
project.
Understand the current state understand what
solution needs to be deployed and then analyse whether the
At the top we'll see how it is managed
in using the classic song so when
we are talking about classic song we do not have a
very well defined or rather these
objectives are not defined in a very
crisp boundaries they are very fluidic in nature they are
driven by various KPIs they are handled
handled by.
They're driven by the problem statements and trigger points that
may arise from the various user
interfaces that the operator has
access to.
Now to understand that the operator
has to go through numerous data sets they have
the operate the network engineers working towards the
the overall network optimization.
They have to be an expert in ram they
have this is entirely experience driven operation and
now after analysing these numerous data set
sets the trigger points that is when the operator
or the network engineer decides OK now
we have to bring in these
on used cases into picture the son use cases the son
Will run in closed loop they will they
They will automate the whole operation.
The optimization operation itself but which module
to use and with what parameters
what settings is something that is handled by the network engine
engineer. So not only does the network engineer need to be.
An expert in the ran they have to be
an expert in so on also they have to have a very
good understanding on how sewn works once
the solution is deployed then the outcome
outcome is analysed.
And and if it is fine good enough if not
not then.
Rollback operations need to be performed.
Now any song customer that we have.
Will find if at all there are challenges found
they will find challenges in these two phases analy
analysing the overall network data coming
up with the problem statement and then triggering the
the right sound solutions.
This is where autopilot comes into picture now
in case of auto autopilot first of all the
objectives are clearly have clearly defined boundaries we have these
three shipped objectives retainability
mobility accessibility availability and throughput
now these are the objectives that the oper
operator will work for and this is the input from the operator for example the
example, the operator can say I want to improve my mobility.
The moment your network is integrated into autopil
autopilot the first thing that it does is it understands the layout of
the land it understands the whole network and
and creates a context.
On top of which it will build its solution.
Once that context is created then
it labels the the
all the all the cells on various charac
characteristics.
Based on this labelling then it'll decide
which ones are the cells which are
positing which are which are contributing positively to
any of these objectives and which are contributing
And with that it will identify the problem
And then comes the solution so problem and
as as you can see the whole analysis is autonomous problem
identification is autonomous and now comes the solution
orchestration that itself is autonomous so
we have free ship modules which are already
already mapped to these objectives.
The autopilot will calibrate the right settings for those objectives and
then deploy those objectives based on the context
that it has created in the previous steps once
Once deployed, the whole result is auto verified.
And then if there is a need
of course, needed rollbacks are found.
So this is how autopilot brings value
How does it do that architecturally what does it look like uh
here I'm trying to explain to you uh in two different sections
on the left hand side you see uh augmented is on
solution itself which brings in the Level 3 automation and the
network optimization but here there are a lot
of inputs needed from the user the topology capacity
coverage frequency and so on with all these
inputs fed into the mentor S on mentor S on then
mentor S on then.
Performs optimization and planning of the network and
it may takes hours or days also.
Now on top of that what we have done is we have
have brought in.
This AI enabled product called autopilot in terms
of input it does not need much from the user just the
objectives that the user aims to improve which
can be throughput availability through mobility
mobility, accessibility and returnability.
Once that is fed OK which objective does
autopilot need to focus on which all object
objective does it need to focus on?
It uses the.
Very badly tested mentally is on mod
modules uh through the NBA
that it provides uh it uses those mod
modules to then deploy a solution in a very pre
precise format so here it leverages on
this battle tested platform but
the whole analysis is handled auton
autonomously by the autopilot and that is where it brings in
in a level 4 automation.
Or autonomous execution.
Obviously it is much faster umm uh as
compared to where it may take days in case
case of autopilot, it may take minutes.
On the coming slides I will talk about
The.
The intrinsic algorithm that that autopil
Autopilot uses, the.
The fundamental framework that it acts upon in order to achieve
its objective.
The first thing that we need to understand is the foundation
on which this entire algorithm is built.
If you take any aiml solution any
any AI product.
The most fundamental aspect of it
Fundamental thing that it needs to achieve is
To understand the layout of the land that it has to act upon take
for example the automated cars if you if
a level of adas or automation it
needs to achieve on the road it has to understand exactly
exactly where it is, what kind of traffic.
What kind of speed zone it is in what is its geograph
geographical location?
What kind of neighbourhood it is in and so on so forth
right that is exactly what aut
autopilot also does the moment you integrate your network
to autopilot it understands the layout of the
land it understands the context it creates a context of
context of the whole network, and how does it do so?
It uses both static and dynamic
characteristics of all the cells in that
network in terms of static labelling we take
into account 23 labels which can be location based
based.
Uh DN server type uh various ident
Then we have dynamic characteristics such as location deploy
deployment and what kind of deployment area it is it is an urban location
location, it is a suburban location or a rural area.
What kind of density is it in is it
in an ultra dense location such
as maybe central business district of Bangalore
Or in a relatively less dense location or
or some sparse location.
And then we have a lot of kpi based or SLI based
labels such as what kind of mobility we have for the
cell which again dynamic in nature the kind of traffic volume
what kind of coverage we have whether the uplink and DL traffic is
good or bad the load share the wise
the wise share and so on and so forth.
Using all of this information it creates
a context it performs uh contextualization
and creates network segments what
are these segments now segmentation of
the network is done based on these characteristics
and some subclusters are created based on the common
characteristics so for example it'll have a bunch of cells which
which are urban ultra dense.
It'll have a bunch of cells which are rude and sparse so
on so forth and this is just one example that I
m thinking but as I said that we apply
apply machine learning capabilities.
Uh to understand and uh analyse
the static and dynamic characteristics and create these segments
And what it does is that it provides a very
good a tremendous context using which the
autopilot understands the the the the
problems of the cell and then goes
on to tailor a solution for
those problematic cells and not the entire network
OK let me have a sip of water because apparently
there's too much information coming out of my mouth so
So give me a second please.
Yeah.
So now that we have created the context let's look at
the entire workflow which the autopilot uses in order
to deploy a solution so the first step
we have already discussed a context is created the
entire network can be contextualised within minutes not
this but just minutes one used case that
we saw was almost 186 cases were
cases were context sliced.
Within.
Within 30 minutes.
Right.
Once this labelling is done static and
dynamic both in nature then context
groupings are created subclusters are created
Identify precise problems and
deploy precise solutions.
Once these sub clusters are created.
Now let's take an example of one particular objective let's say
mobility now operator wants OK my mobility I
have to ensure that I have high mobility in all these CL
these clusters.
Now the parameters defining
A high performing cell may differ from
an urban ultra dense location from a
rural ultra rural sparse location so
even the thresholds that define whether a cell
is contributing positively to this objective or neg
negatively to this objective is depending
depending dependent on the context.
Let's say for an urban ultra dense location we have
the subcluster.
What we do is we identify what are my top 95th
percentile cells.
And what are the parameters how how they're behaving uh
we identify that what is the kpi
of those cells and that becomes my benchmark that defines
defines the threshold.
Above that threshold the cells are positive are
contributing positively to this particular objective and
and below that they are not.
Contributing positively rather contributing negatively to the object
objective.
Now once these threshold are defined again
again, this is very dynamic in nature.
These thresholds can change
on a very regular basis we can perform this
threshold computation on a daily basis and
it can happen in minutes so we
do not have a standard solution for weeks and months
rather it is very real time it is
It is very.
What do you say?
Uh uh you know uh take into account the latest
latest happenings in the network.
So now threshold computation is done.
Uh and umm after the threshold computation
is completed uh comes the problem ident
identification or problem detection as I said you ident
identify the top it's 95 percentile cells and
then identify the cells which are not contributing or not match
Then once you have identified these cells
you know that these are problematic cells and you can
only focus on those cells you can you can provide
the net the solution to
to those cells.
Right umm as opposed to uh any other Sol
solution where you have to deploy we we generally go with the
uh orchestration of the entire network or we
we go with a solution deployment on the entire network.
Here we are targeting only the problematic sense now
not only do we have very tailored
precise threshold definition we also have tailored
tailored solution orchestration.
The for to achieve the mobility object
objective the modules on modules that come into use are
are an R.
PCI and prach now for an urban sparse location
the parameters or the settings needed for those partic
particular sound modules.
Would be may be different from the ones in urban
uh, in rural or sparse uh area, right?
So even solution orchestration part the Sol
module that we deploy have very precise setting
settings which are tailored as per that context
And all of it is done autonomously so here you can
see without manual intervention we have identified the
problem we have and
and in a very precise manner only the problematic sense and
we have found the solution in a very orgas
very precise manner for those problem
problematic cells.
And they're tailored to the needs as per the context
of that particular set.
So this was the entire workflow
of the execution.
Of an autopilot.
Of the autopilot in order to achieve any of these objectives.
We will move on to see how what objectives
could we currently have this is the current view
of currently available objectives and mod
modules obviously it is subject
to change a lot of places where the pilot is
is ongoing.
Upon completion the status will change but as of today
these are uh different objectives and modules that we
have to offer in case of 4G we have return
returnability throughput availability accessibility and mobility
mobility objectives.
And in case of 5G we have throughput accessibility and mobility
now in order to achieve these object and these are categories
of the objectives each of these objective categ
category will have the corresponding different well defin
defined object is what will be a part of this category
for example mobility will have these
different objectives cells that are
are.
That have good intra Lt mobility good W
WCBMPSHO base mobility irad based
mobility and so on so forth now to achieve these
these objectives.
Uh what are the solutions that will be deployed in order to
fix the problematic cells or uh
improve the performance in the problematic cells those are the
son modules that will be invoked from
from the autopilot. If the cell is not.
Is not performing to the as per the
threshold identified during the course of threshold or if ident
identification so these are the modules these are
standard modules so whenever autopilot is
executed it needs to be ensured that cor
corresponding son has the licence for these modules it
the underlying son should have these modules if these modules
modules are not there then.
For any given objective, let's say.
Uh for uh mobility if uh AN
ANR is not present on the pcip rach is present then
then only those modules will be invoked.
Right so here you can see a lot of places pilot
doesn't still needed uh a lot of places pilot is ongo
ongoing and when that pilot is available uh pilot
is successfully completed they'll be declared ga where
wherever you see a release mentioned that is where
where the.
Module has already achieved G or general availability
OK so these were the details of how autop
autopilot works we will quickly
and delve into the results
results that Autopilot has brought in.
These are the results from the pilot that
we are doing for T-Mobile and obviously by the
way these are customer specific this is this is still under
foaa so it
cannot be shared with other customers this is for Nokia internal
internal use only.
This particular slide.
Now in order to.
Deliberate or in order to identify or rather judge
the performance of autopilot itself these are
the categories under which we have eval
evaluated it for T-Mobile which is automated
automated, operational intelligence, improved precision.
Reduce time for network in suboptimal state and
improved network performance.
Automated operational intelligence what it means is
how fast can we uh what kind of autom
automation or autonomous execution can we bring in using
uh autopilot now if the
autopilot is not used the phase where
we can textilize the whole network would
take weeks now we do not have a formal contextualization phase
I don't think any operator does that but primarily what it means
is the whole data analysis understanding of the network
would still be needed so if you are doing it for the first time
time, it may take.
Days maybe weeks to understand the context of the entire
entire network.
Now in case of autopilot that can be achieved within 30 minutes
so all the labelling static and dynamic is done
done and these contexts are created within 30 minutes.
And within 30 minutes we are able to.
Evaluate the objective also so we can identify which cells are
Are contributing positively.
To the set objectives and which are not
so basically you are able to identify the
the problematic sense as well within 30 minutes.
Then comes the aspect of improved
precision.
Uh what we want is that we are able to achieve
the same results as that of song
by targeting minimal number
of cells so that we have more precised solution
of more precise operation
so here in this graph for example it
it's a little small. I'm sorry for that, but I'll try to explain.
The first bar that you see is the.
Uh subclusters with dynamic threshold so basically
these this these are the subclusters that were target
Right so for example these were the number of subclust
subclusters on which uh the operation ran the 2nd
second one you see is the number of parameters per
sub clusters were that were actually changed
changed using the.
Autopilot.
Product and as you can see it's
very small in number in most of the cases it is not
going beyond 10 right and we are able
able to achieve the same.
Level of improvement uh targeting
Targeting minimal number of changes.
And the last bar that you see is focus percent
percentage of problematic cells as I had mentioned
with Sean if you want to for example run
coc on uh entire cluster and find all
the outages you may have to run that solution
on a entire subcluster or entire network
and then identify those outages with
with Autopilot. You can actually target.
A very small percentage of those cells now in this case
for example prach had targeted just below
below 10%.
Almost 9% of the cells uh to uh to bring in
the same amount of improvement uh for the object
objective that we were uh aiming at and none of these do you see
goes beyond 20% apart from an rvln
cclv slv but most of the cases what we
see is we are able to achieve the
same amount of network improvement by targeting very
very few cells.
And that is the precise precise nature of our solution deployment I'll
give you an example of coc itself in one used case where
where.
Using mentor is on 5000
cells were identified were analysed
analysed to identify 7 outages.
Using autopilot the same number of outages or the same out
outages could be identified by analysing just 92 cells
so that is the level of precision we are talking about
and it's not just about targeting
the problematic cells or a fewer number of cells
it's also about defining precise
parameters for those solutions so
So the modules that will be involved will be.
With the tailored settings as per the context of that
particular set and that is what brings in the high precision.
Reduce time for the network in sub optimization state
or sub optimal state what it means is that you are
are able to.
Identify the problems and fix the problems at a much faster
rate if we look at mod
module execution we were able to
achieve module execution 22 times
faster more for when we had run multiple
modules Mr OC NR and so on so forth almost
almost 22% faster.
87 time percent faster problem detection
and repair.
87% and that is because we are not
Deploying these modules on the entire network but we
we are going with a very precise approach.
A very surgical way to approach the problem
And last but not least improved performance improved
network performance as I said that
that.
Despite targeting very few cells we are
able to achieve total parity and
in a lot of cases improvement as well over
and above the optimization that we had achieved
using the son module the classic
method is on itself right in a lot of cases we see a lot of
improvement and at least total parity was there
Then we talked about improved precision solution orchestration
Umm of course we have talked
about it earlier also umm the the
solution that we are deploying that itself is very precise
precise in nature.
So this was for TMO the current side
talks about uh our results in nea
Used case already which is out which is
out in the public domain.
In case of stc almost a million corrected us
users were there and this.
Trial was done during the Hajj period where the operators are
they freeze their networks they generally do not touch their networ
networks they don't make any changes in the networks just to make sure
that you know everything goes fine and there are the
whole event goes uneven the whole Hajj
Hajj period goes on in eventful.
There autopilot was deployed we had almost
a million connected users 20,000 simultaneously
simultaneously connected users.
Who were moving from one place to another, so a few.
Know about haj you know that the pilgrims move
move from one place to another.
And they keep on moving.
So there is a very high level of mobility what we
were able to achieve was 20% higher
14% more connected users and
10% higher ddl throughput all
this by doing almost 10,000
000 autonomous optimizations.
Per hour in a network where generally no
changes are allowed during the time of Hajj so
that is the level of improvement that
Now here we will look at the various deployment models off
song so autopilot is a soft
software only delivery which can be deployed.
On.
Just one second please.
Yeah so which can be deployed on the NMCC
NMCCP blueprint solution umm it can be deployed on
top of the umm so the the
blueprint solution from nccp it can be deployed on top of HP
DL360 Gen 11 hardware with
hardware with Electra storage.
From product line, this is the offering that we have.
And then there are various other deployment models where
we.
Have to bring in the services engagement now from.
The blueprint solution the initial configuration that we started with
was one provisional node 3
computational node and six control nodes that is some around
10 servers but we were able to optimise it and
What we need is 7 servers one for provision 1
1 computational and one control node.
We are working on uh reducing it
further so that uh we are able to achieve umm for
pocs for example uh we can uh for uh a target
of 160 K cells uh we can use uh the
deployment on uh A4 server configuration where
one for will be for provision node and three for comput
computational and control.
Then there are various deployment models where serv
services engagements can be brought into play
Umm one is the bare metal approach itself which uh where
the current minimum configuration uh that services team
has tried upon is for 50 cases can be used for poc
Pocs and.
Uh and pilots up and so on where just
4 servers are needed then we have these other
deployment models this for bare metal then we have that other deploy
deployment models where even the hardware is provided by the customer
and Nokia provides only the ohc
ohcp ocp and the platform components from
components from NMCCP.
Umm yet another umm approach is where
uh the ocp comes from
the customer the hardware and ocp both come from
All these three deployment modules require serv
services engagement.
OK.
So this was all about what autopilot is doing as
of now, what was the deployment model and so on so forth.
Here in this slide what I talked about is the
future, the vision that Autopilot has.
As of now it's what is already available is
network contextualization and algor
algorithm orchestration.
The next step would be to bring in custom objectives
and module registration and what does that mean as of now
we have some preshhed objectives
and the son modules which are mapped to these objectives
objectives.
Our customers already have hundreds of adapted modules
of their own that they use to orchestrate their network.
Now.
They should be able to define their own objectives and they
should be able to register their own modules to
these objectives in order to deploy their solution
That is the next level of flex
flexibility that we want to bring in with autopilot so along with the object
objectives that we are shipping.
It is possible to define custom objectives and
register the custom uh
modules or the adapter modules by the users uh
to these objectives that is the next level that we
Then comes the extreme intent based on what it
means is as of now we have objective we have int
intents intent based solution but then still
still this rule driven.
With extreme intent based on umm what
we want to achieve is that we
want the customer to only give the intent and
we derive the rule using that intent the autopil
autopilot drives that rule using that intent.
And ultimately what we want to achieve
is predictive problem solving so as of now autopilot is
reactive in nature it acts upon the KP
KPIs, network performance and so on so forth.
What we want to achieve is that autopilot is able to predict
the problems and then provide solutions.
In order to address those problems proactively.
That is the ultimate aim that we have for Autopilot.
So this I come to the end of the presentation for
more information. We have links here and.
The list of contacts are also there from portfolio
management.
You can contact toya from product management you can
contact me and for any
architectural topics Mohan can
be contacted or else for all the topics you
You can contact me and then I can.
Direct it towards.
Towards the relevant stakeholders and get your answers.
Thank you, vikas. Maybe we shall take.
Some questions that has been coming several quest
questions related to the.
Day that not only for the 15
minute intervals but also for
the trace based data do
OK, I'm not.
Having access to umm the
if you can give me just one minute I'll just
just go on to the.
The questions.
The question is many customers have asked
asked real time Autopilot.
And the one second reaction time instead of 50
minutes, is there any plans for this?
OK I think one second as of now no
What we have so for example sdc itself we
were able to initially the reaction time
we were analysing some 8 hours data and
and all that.
Uh we brought it down to 15 minutes uh as
of now umm we do not really
have that plan to reduce it further umm but then
yes in future probably we'll come down to 5
But as of now it is there are other activities which are on the cards
cards.
OK then the next next next
question is that is autopilot deploy
deployed commercially?
Anywhere globally or is it still
in trial or proof of concept phase
phase?
We do not have a commercial deployment as such, but.
With TMO we are we have done a
very extensive pilot and hope
hopefully by end of 2025 or maybe first
half of 2026 we should be able to deploy
it commercially.
OK. Thank you then.
Next questions now we are going a bit different area
the question is many optim
optimization activities gain better results when
applied to bigger area than just
the poorly performing sales how
does outer payler autopilot takes this into
into account?
Could you repeat that question I'm sorry uh yes yes yes many
optimization activities gain better results
than applied to bigger area than us
than us.
Poorly performing sales how does aut
Autopilot takes this into account?
OK so.
As I said that.
What we are trying to achieve is more pre
precision with autopilot.
If we are analysing these subclusters and
these subclusters are.
Created based on the existing characterist
characteristics of the soils.
Cells of similar characteristics are grouped together and
the threshold to identify whether
a cell is performing poorly or not.
Is.
Calculated or computed for that particular subcluster if there are
more number of cells which are problematic then obvious
obviously the number of cells which are uh which we are
targeting will be higher and
of course there are set parameters that
can be defined in order to decide what
all parameters should be targeted for solution
So that is also something which is a flexibility that is already available
Uh maybe umm Mohan can give more
information on this uh Mohan maybe umm if
umm, if you can take that question for me.
Sure because I yeah I am at least I was typing
this but it's a very very valid question so
when we have this kind of solution orch
orchestration it is just not the problem at excel but
we also want to have additional cells
which are needed to be orchestrated so that it can
provide the much more optimal value so that is the reason autop
autopilot brings in a capability called a supplementary
So it's just not based on the solution we are orchestrating along
with the problem at excel it will also try to include the supp
supplementary cells as well so for in classic
example it can be the reuse modules so the
the reuse modules when we are doing this.
It is just not the problematic self by just changing the
RSA or apci value for a a supplement
supplementary cell can also resolve the problem at excel's problem so
that's the focus area and it can be
compensate even it can be taken for sell out
outage compensation so even though you have an outage cell actual
compensation cell is also needed for it
to be offloading those traffic as well for the out
out itself so.
Autopilot is taking care of these based on the solutions which
it is orchestrating.
Yeah and especially for reuse uh modules
modules that we have such as PC and P.
It is just not possible to target only the problematic cells if you're
re changing the swapping the pcis or changing the pcis.
The conflicts also have to be resolved so all those changes are
are handled by Autopilot.
Then I think that this this is our last quest
question now is the question is
when AI uses will be
extended to help our customers to
identify the optimal parameter setting
settings at cell level.
For different run features that goes beyond PCI
per us and an R
is there this kind of planning
Currently.
Are we? Is there any plans for that?
OK so.
Maybe I need some follow up information on that
uh front what do we mean by that umm
Umm, by.
By when we say that OK we are targeting
specific cells or at bring
bringing in AI at cell level so OK there is a concept
concept for AI for ran.
And AI.
Or ran AI itself right so if
the domain in which autopilot
works on is AI for run in which
it has it acts upon externally it does
not bring in the AI logic or deploys
AI logic at ram level rather it's a
it's a tool that sits outside and analyses the ran and
then invokes needed functionality or needed changes in the in the
in the.
Ran using the.
The machine learning data that it has gathered and analysed
So if I'm not understanding this question correctly
maybe you can share some more information
information on that and we can have a follow up.
Mohan if you have something to add on on this particular question
question, I'm not sure if I understood it correctly.
Yeah unless I answered this so I think
if this question is more towards
bringing in the multi vendor capability
so the solution orchestration is already the
sound solutions are already multi vendor so the same
support is extended for autopil
autopilot as well so if that is not the
underlying question maybe we can take this offline as well with
well with Samuel.
OK.
Then just one one thing I would like to highlight.
AI autopilot is an independent product but it does
use the underlying class
classic son to deploy these solutions so all the
capabilities that are available and so on are available
in autopilot because ultimately it is working on top
of our mentor is on so function
flexibilities or functionality such as mvie and all
Yes and then one one question about
some Samsung so called support is the autopilot
autopilot supporting Samsung.
That works.
As of now son itself does not
not support Samsung.
And there are two reasons for that one is that
Samsung itself is not a part of versus II
So what it needs is that we have
Take help from customer to get the needed inter
interface. Pick under NDA and.
Many a times the solution from Samsung
may be customised from 1 customer to another.
We do not have an umbrella interface spec
we may not have an umbrella interface spec so that is one reason
why as of now Samsung is not
handled by son another
Another reason is that.
There has to be a good business use case so
far whatever queries we have got we have not received
a used case where song has to be included so in a nutshe
nutshell, as of now there is no plan.
To provide this functionality for Samsung
Have support for Samsung?
Thank you vikas thank thank you all
the listeners I think that we are ending this session and also
thank thanks for the raya Mohan
and vikas about presentation and
and active answering to the questions.
Thank you. Final word, final words because.
Yeah so thank you for joining this
session I hope it it gave you some information
on what autopilot is what it is doing and how it is doing
Yeah we we have some
functionalities and capabilities already available and
quite a lot of them are under development so yeah
let's let's let's
let's push it forward. Thank you.
All right thank you so much everyone for joining in
we can go ahead and close this call please do not forget to claim your
credits for the session and once you've done that you are free
to go thank you so much everyone for joining in and have a great
great day. Thank you and bye bye. See you.